[Music]
on this saturday night
evacuation alert tens of thousands of
people in bc
are told to get ready to run as
unrelenting wildfires grow and devour
entire communities but some are refusing
to budge
canada's golden games canadian olympians
cap off a record run in tokyo
so who will be tapped to carry canada's
flag at the closing ceremonies
a mandate to vaccinate this has become a
very political and emotional debate
a growing list of canadian businesses
are requiring workers to receive a covit
19 vaccine
but without government legislation
companies could be left
in legal limbo and long in the tooth
how a six-year-old girl in alberta made
a 25
000 year old discovery
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin tonight in
british columbia's interior where tens
of thousands are now
on evacuation alert a massive wildfire
is raging in the central okanagan
burning perilously close to several
towns and cities
that fire is estimated at 55 000
hectares you see there in dark red
and the surrounding area has already
been evacuated nearly a thousand
properties
residents in the huge swath of land you
can see there in yellow are now being
told to be ready to leave at a moment's
notice
including around 40 thousand residents
in the city of vernon
that fire has been burning for about
three weeks but has grown
significantly just over the past few
days some residents say
more should have been done to fight the
fire before it surged out of control
ahmad agahi is in kamloops for us
tonight with our top story
ahmad well we are entering the peak of
the bc
wildfire season and this particular
white rock lake fire burning between
kamloops
and vernon is the largest it has grown a
hundred square kilometers since friday
morning
and now sits at 55 000 hectares
and over the last 72 hours it has jumped
its way to the top
of the priority list of more than 300
active
wildfires in bc and although thousands
of people in smaller communities have
had to leave their homes
there are now evacuation alerts for
larger cities like vernon
armstrong chase and even properties in
the eastern part of
kamloops
this blaze became a big problem thursday
when it jumped
a highway and swallowed up the community
of monty lake
it has caused devastation destruction
damaging buildings and burning cars
from there it has been moving northeast
forcing evacuation orders in smaller
communities in its path
many leaving with just a shirt on their
backs and their pets
and finding their way to evacuation
centers set up in
cities like kamloops and those same
evacuees and many who are
on order to leave are frustrated that
the fire
has not been contained yet they kind of
left the stranded
i mean they they say that they're doing
a whole bunch but
realistically they haven't um this fire
started and it was 10 hectares
through to 300 and even the local
loggers they were trying to get cats up
there and put it out and
the government and the forest ministry
said no don't
let it burn and that's part of the
problem we live out in the country
so if we see a fire we're not going to
wait for the forestry to put it out
we're going to do it ourselves
but no not there you can't do that
because this is the results of
politicians talking
now as the size of the white rock lake
fire grows so does the response from the
bc wildfire service currently there are
13 helicopters fighting this fire 38
pieces of heavy
equipment there are hundreds of fire
crews and an incident
management team on site and as we
mentioned the conditions that have
played
a large part in the explosion of the
fire
size well there's no relief really in
sight in terms of rain
ahead and although it is cooler and
cloudy
today the wildfire service is expecting
hot dry conditions to come back as early
as monday and stay within the next
couple of weeks as well jeff stay safe
thanks ahmad
and wildfires are also triggering mass
evacuations in greece
this dramatic footage was taken
overnight from the island of avija
ferries plucked about 1400 people from
beaches as flames closed in
dozens of fires are now burning across
the country one volunteer firefighter
has died
scores of homes businesses and farms
have been destroyed
and more wildfires are also threatening
thousands of homes in northern
california the so-called dixie fire is
the biggest blaze burning in the u.s
and it's now the third largest in
california history
it's already destroyed more than 250
homes and it's threatening
more than ten thousand other buildings
police say eight people are missing
the dixie fire has burned over 180
thousand hectares
and it's only about 20 percent contained
well to the olympics now and we have
some breaking news to bring to you
team canada has just revealed its flag
bearer the canadian olympian chosen to
represent the country
at sunday's closing ceremonies is
drumroll
damien warner the 31 year old from
london ontario was crowned the world's
best all-around athlete warner captured
canada's first ever gold medal
in the grueling decathlon finishing with
an olympic record-setting score
in one of the game's oldest and most
storied events
it is an honor of my lifetime to be
named as the flight bearer for the
closing ceremonies of these games i've
watched these games and i've followed
these athletes for so long and i
understand that
this honor could have went to anybody on
this team there's so many great
performances over these games
congratulations damian meanwhile team
canada continued its winning ways on
the water laurence vincent lapoint and
katie vincent earned a bronze in the
first ever women's c2
500 meter canoe race today the olympians
ended up
in the water after accidentally tipping
the canoe while
sharing a post-race hug until this year
canoe had been an exclusively
male olympic sport that win brings
canada's metal hall to 23
team canada's best ever performance at a
non-boycotted summer games
china still leads the pack with 38 gold
medals but the u.s has the most medals
overall with 108.
canada is sitting in 14th place
olympic organizers meanwhile are
reporting 22
new cases of kovit 19 connected to the
games
officials say 16 of those are among
residents of japan well the rest are
foreigners
now that brings the number of total k
covet 19 cases related to the games to
404
infections in tokyo have surged over the
last few weeks
but the olympics chief covet 19 expert
says there is no evidence of any spread
between the olympic bubble
and the broader japanese population
the easing of pandemic restrictions in
many parts of this country
is fueling debate about mandatory
vaccinations
several canadian post-secondary
institutions are now moving forward with
plans to ensure that students and staff
are vaccinated before the start of the
school year and this week the prime
minister weighed
in on the growing debate shawn o'shea
has the details
with canada bracing for a possible
fourth wave of covet 19 cases it's the
subject now confronting businesses and
governments head on
in the last week this has become a very
political and emotional
debate whether to require individuals to
prove they've been vaccinated
either as a condition of say dining at a
restaurant
or going to their job this is what the
majority wants that we should go for it
but popular opinion aside the idea of
requiring someone to be vaccinated is
tricky
employers who think that well of course
i can do this it's the right thing to do
i think are going to find themselves on
the other side of a wrongful dismissal
claim
south of the border many companies
already require workers to be vaccinated
cnn just fired three employees for
showing up at work without getting their
shots
united airlines has mandated all its u.s
based employees to be vaccinated by late
october
or risk being terminated the prime
minister says the government is mulling
the question for at least
one group to look at mandatory
vaccinations for
federal employees but provinces like
ontario and alberta have rejected the
idea of making vaccinations compulsory
if we reach the point where you have to
show a vaccine passport to have a glass
of wine on an outdoor patio
but not to be a kindergarten teacher
like how much sense does that make
still carlton university just announced
students living in residence or playing
varsity sports
need to prove they're vaccinated seneca
college in toronto went farther
it will require all staff and students
to be vaccinated
if they want to set foot on campus we
can't force people to get vaccinated but
if we take away
activities such as indoor dining gyms
sporting events
because that's the responsible thing to
do then that may be the way to get
more people vaccinated and a patchwork
of policies doesn't work says this
lawyer
you can imagine a scenario where you
have a building where you have a bank
on the sixth floor and for example a
software company on the seventh floor
and the banking employees must be
vaccinated and the software company has
no ability
to mandate vaccination the only answer
he says clear direction from governments
either that vaccinations are required or
not
shadow sha global news toronto and the
pandemic has also prompted a rethink
over how we work
besides the countless employees who've
been working from home governments
around the world are also exploring
plans to reduce the standard work
week pilot programs have found that four
day work weeks can actually
boost productivity and gaviola has more
on the calls to reconsider
the nine to five in 1926 henry ford the
man at the helm of the ford motor
company instituted the weekend
shutting down factories on saturday and
sunday requiring employees to work five
days a week from monday to friday
other companies and countries followed
suit work is a very different thing than
it was
in the 20th century and so i don't think
the five-day work
week serves us very well the david
suzuki foundation implemented four-day
work
weeks in the 1990s staff say it makes
for happier more creative and productive
employees who have more time to spend
with family
pursue hobbies and even volunteer in the
community i work monday to thursday
and on fridays i spend some time
volunteering at canadian blood services
i wouldn't be able to do that if i were
working five days a week findings from
the largest study of the four-day work
week in the world
conducted in iceland over four years
were released in july
the researchers conclusions were
overwhelmingly positive and 85 percent
of workers in iceland are either on a
four-day work schedule or heading down
that path
in the u.s legislation was introduced
last week to shorten the standard work
week
put forward by democrat mark takano from
southern california
he tweeted that the nature of work is
rapidly changing we must keep up
economist linda nazareth says the
reduction of traffic and pollution
associated with a 20 percent reduction
in commutes
can be a major driver of the four day
work week movement i
think the environment and climate change
is something that's going to be factored
into work a lot more
in the next two years five years ten
years and
that may mean we go to a four-day work
week but in a tight labor market the
onus will be on employees to push for it
we have this mindset that you have to be
on or available all the time
particularly if you're anything but a
very junior worker and
it is going to be a really hard sell i
think to see this widely adopted
compressed work weeks have been trialled
and scrapped over the decades
in the 80s as a response to soaring
prices at the pumps
and abandoned as gas prices came down
and productivity dropped
the time will tell if the pandemic will
be the catalyst that begins a long-term
shift in how
and how often we work ann gaviola global
news
toronto a tentative agreement has been
reached to keep border workers
on the job the four-year deal follows 36
hours of mediated talks
after more than 9 000 border services
workers staged a work to rule campaign
yesterday
it stalled traffic at some of canada's
busiest international crossings
employees haven't had a contract in
three years the deal between ottawa and
the union was reached
just before the restrictions at the
canada u.s border are set to ease on
monday
that will allow fully vaccinated
americans their first chance to cross
into canada for pleasure trips
since the pandemic began in march of
last year
still ahead impending impeachment the
mounting political pressure for new
york's governor
to resign
welcome back political pressure is
building for new york's governor andrew
cuomo to resign
a damning report alleges cuomo sexually
assaulted former staff members and
fostered a negative work environment
now the first criminal complaint has
been brought forward by one of those
accusers
and could result in charges reggie
shakini reports
is to have been assaulted by the
governor she's one of eleven who have
come forward with allegations
a report from the state's attorney
general last week laid bare what it said
were undeniable facts
of a hostile workplace this is the first
criminal complaint to be filed
i commend them on the bravery for coming
forward and now it's time for us to
begin our investigation
the governor's legal team pounced on the
initial report claiming a predetermined
narrative
painting the governor as the victim
while hitting back at the independent
investigators
as being politically driven the governor
deserves to be treated fairly
and he must be that did not happen here
if this charge has proven true the
governor could face arrest
and a misdemeanor charge and it's more
reasoned why his party is widening the
gap
are you now calling on him to resign yes
he's lost the support from key democrats
in washington
and in his own backyard we are
considering
developing articles of impeachment of
governor cuomo
cuomo's lawyers intend to provide
evidence by next week
in his defense to stave off political
elimination but with a job approval
rating below 30 percent
cuomo's on borrowed time impeachment is
backed by a majority of state lawmakers
and as more investigations into his
behavior open up this is obviously a
very high profile investigation
there's a lot of information out there
his political future is on the line
with few people coming to his defense
democrats have been quick to cut ties
with scandal-plagued lawmakers in sharp
contrast to republicans who still stand
by a twice impeached former president
if cuomo can run through the headwinds
of his own impeachment it's unclear if
he could even seek a fourth term in 2022
given the lack of support and any
outcomes of current or former
investigations
jeff reggie takini in washington thanks
reggie
still ahead calls for accountability in
beirut
one year after the deadly port blast
you're watching global national
welcome back this week people in beirut
marked one year since that huge ammonium
nitrate explosion
killed 200 people causing devastating
damage in the lebanese capital
people there are angry that no senior
official has been held accountable
and they're also desperate for something
to be done about the country's deep
economic crisis and political
dysfunction redmond shannon reports
the new memorial for the beirut blast is
made from the debris of the explosion
many lebanese say for now justice for
the victims and political reform
are more important than sculptures the
killers
have complete impunity of their crime
and with already pretending that
something has passed on the anniversary
that frustration was visible on the
streets of beirut
and from french president emmanuel
macron who demanded fundamental change
as he chaired a lebanon aid conference
to help those
most in need i can tell you that
children for example now
replace staples such as cheese and egg
with only water and time and families
and parents tell me this
the economic crisis began a year before
the blast
medicines and fuel are scarce
electricity
intermittent we are looking at a crisis
where the very survival of children
is now at stake i'm sorry by the way i'm
sweating because
i have no electricity and it's 32
degrees here
economists say the collapse of the
currency is a result of decades of
mismanagement by lawmakers
so you import a lot but you are
subsidizing
and we as lebanese we were living above
our means you need a new mentality new
people who will
protect the public resources who will
manage the resources efficiently parties
have struggled to agree on a new
government
even amid the crisis this is partly
because the unique political system sees
key roles shared among religious groups
sectarian violence this week has
highlighted deep divides
that persist we used to talk about
failed states
you know we're past failed states you
know this is like
stateless uh somebody mentioned today
something like state capture
the political and social influence of
iran is seen by many
as the most insurmountable barrier to
change
some see only one solution for
themselves you know definitely anybody
who had another citizenship has already
left
because this is their password to live
hope
along with food and electricity remain
in
short supply in lebanon redmond shannon
global news
london she's been dubbed the fossil
fairy next meet the little girl who just
gave a big gift
to paleontologists in alberta
welcome back alberta is home to 587
animal species and for a long time that
list has not included
camels the desert dwellers haven't
roamed north america since the last ice
age
but newly unearthed evidence is now
shedding light on their prehistoric life
and as sarah ryan explains it's all
thanks to a six-year-old girl
six-year-old abby darby will never
forget this particular beach day
on the beach sand i thought i
saw a cool rock but then i digged it out
and it wasn't a rock instead of throwing
it back into jackfish lake
she ran to show her family the unusual
find
i thought after that it would be really
cool if i could tell her
exactly what it was because we all had
our guesses
grandma she had a clog
guest but all the other ones
um think that it was a tooth abby's aunt
sent a video of the fossil to the
university of alberta
it's definitely a tooth you can see it
right away and it's definitely mammal
because it has the multiple roots
a lot of what we see in dinosaurs or
lizards or other animals is a single
root
phd student mark powers looked carefully
at the tooth cusps and pits
upon looking at some specimens here at
the university of alberta in our
teaching collections i can confirm it's
definitely a camel
family member that's right a camel in
alberta
power says fossil records indicate
camels originated here in north america
abby was thrilled by the news i think
that
it was amazing the university estimates
the tooth to be between 22
and 25 000 years old there was huge
glaciers that were covering most of
alberta during that time so there would
have been
some ravines where the ice sheets were
retreating away from each other
where we would get a lot of water
influence from the militant glaciers and
that's where animals probably would have
hung out
power said by analyzing the fossilized
tooth isotopes
researchers could learn a lot about how
long the animal lived what it ate
and how it migrated abby's family plans
to donate the specimen to the royal
alberta museum
so when next year i'm in on grade one i
can show my friends
they would think it was very very cool
sarah ryan global news very cool
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm jeff semple tonight
your canada is tiverton nova scotia
please keep sending us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night